[Music]
in my bad news submitted by Pizza Pizza
Pizza oh I love [ __ ] Peter oh
yeah oh yeah all in pineapple yeah I
would define a blonde penis no pineapple
yeah my three favorite is a pepperoni
pineapple and ham and then a margarita I
like a pineapple pineapple on like cpk
used to do this like they used to put
pineapple on their barbecue chicken
pizzas oh there's Bob you chicken
pineapple and they would and they would
add bacon to fire dip it in the ranch
mmm okay oh I'm salivation all right a
guy had to quit his job after a mistake
in text made things weird between him
and his boss oh [ __ ] why'd he had to
quit was he like would you like to bring
dick for sure and wait for you to
something I take later no I mean kind of
in that realm sorta all right so this
story's about this kid named Corey he's
19 years old he used to work at the
front desk of a small web design company
in Chicago and so he received this text
just for you by the way I'm not like
sexy
Corey couldn't be that small to have a
front desk what we don't even have a
front desk at JK oh you mean the company
the company he's got to be pretty big to
have a front desk person and it's a nice
chair at the front desk is that Bruce
Lee on his chest oh that is Bruce Lee on
his chest yeah so he received this text
I'm making you come at 12:00 on Friday
so he responds with first off you're not
making me do [ __ ] second off I don't
remember scheduling any dick
appointments side I face wait does he
know he misunderstood the tags yeah yeah
Samantha's next one says this is your
boss blah blah blah got a new number
oh it's like he just froze he was like
oh [ __ ] what do I do
the ended up texts or nothing tweeting
it out I'm making you [ __ ] yeah I'm
tweeting it out and he was just like he
was just saying at this moment I knew I
[ __ ] very respectful what he did cuz
he's like wait a minute like you don't
owe me with a book are you right and he
could've been like lol my bad yeah like
I didn't save your like how was I
supposed to know this your new number
exactly like I would have respected him
way more why do you have to put it but
then so this was around 2 p.m. right
when this whole exchange happened she
didn't respond and then I'll be giving
you a call tomorrow to discuss the terms
of your employment with us not fair yeah
I heat the boss should have led with hey
this is my new number I'm making you
come at 12:00 this way yeah we're coming
in yeah what kind of English is that the
boss is the [ __ ]
you're scheduled to come in at 12:00
well maybe that was the boss shooting
her shot oh yeah I'm in man in being
like I mean you know they'd be like oh
he turned me down actually that's not
what I thought what I was trying to say
and we need to talk because this is
inappropriate
we we we did talk this way
don't put your mouth around the other
layers I can't my mouth doesn't damn you
tried it being that at the microphone
I would I would make sorry [ __ ] guy
like all the dudes getting wet though
yeah yeah so then after he was saying so
he tweeted that out things got out of
hand because it went really viral and
then that's when his entire office
including his boss found out that this
suite went viral and
they asked the company reached out to
him about it and asked not to be
mentioned because there's so much
negative energy surrounding it and so he
just ended up deciding to quit there's
so much positive energy you're working
for the wrong company I would love that
share publicity Thank You resign due to
the fact that Twitter blew the situation
up Danny I mean okay
what type of company is it you know like
it what is I cuz it has I mean like if
it was it doesn't apply you know it
doesn't I don't know why it has to be a
wholesome company like if it was like a
like a church audio book store some [ __ ]
like that I don't know like [ __ ] I
don't know like like [ __ ] children's
books and this [ __ ] happened that's a
very funny thing like it was really
funny like that happen if ik oh my god
this is dope can I put it out
some people do perceive like funny
situations as coming down on them though
it'll just just kind of crack yeah like
they can't handle the joke and they just
go they feel like it's embarrassing all
around yeah I think I texted you
something where it was like a [ __ ] up
type of and then it was just like it
ended you know what I [ __ ] said to
somebody one time somebody I used to
work with as well like I mean webmaker
on accident
I sent I sent something I sent a check
that was like because I was texting
somebody that was asking me for a dick
pic and I was texting oh [ __ ] that I
work with and I replied with lol I can't
right now I just jerked off maybe later
I fit into the wrong person to a guy and
they replied luckily they were comedians
the guy the guy said it to you just send
me a [ __ ] picture with like this his
ass but maybe this will help
[Laughter]
that's pretty good yeah I know I just
jerked off yeah I think bar sex to me
before but your ass meant it to be 40
years Oh cute ass
I love you [ __ ] doing bear talk yeah
glove you cuny beer pong and oh Jesus I
don't accident like in the Dino right no
I'd like two big groups I don't know I
think you I think I remember something
about like you texting him but then it
was to Gina she she ends up doing like
her crying emoji my god cute no I mean I
think I got I mean I told you guys this
before but I did get a text from a
married dude when I was in high school
and he was like we're not a high school
well the family member mmm
so this who is married so he was texting
his booty call whatever because his wife
was out of town and they ended up
texting me that he was he had a booty
call named TIFF - no underage sex oh I
have no idea but oh you know it's cuz we
were texting at the same time he where
he you gotta make [ __ ] and then he ends
up telling me like I'm so sorry like
please don't tell my wife what you do
though you did yeah for you yeah oh
you're good for you yeah I did that as a
little kid
good for you yeah this is a close family
member I mean yeah yeah of course that's
where we're at out we were at a birthday
party and then it was uh so imagine if
Tony Hawk and his friends were all
adults so that's the kind of parents
they were right and then so he was young
I get what you saying but you know it's
a reckless skater day okay
skater people okay so so we're in the
backyard right oh you know we're having
a birthday party kids are having fun
and if we go around the alley on our
bicycles it didn't me then in my
neighbor we saw we saw her auntie Cheryl
she was like she would come down and
hang out but she wasn't kissing her
husband she was kissing somebody else oh
and then they caught us and they've
stared at us and they're just looking at
us and we were just on our bicycles like
well we were just like this like
that's so cute cos kids don't know how
to hide so they're just like right in
front like we just wave - yeah we just
like we didn't know what to do and then
she's like that to share that's not
uncle so uh so we're like oh this is not
right idiot so the house was here the
alley was here so it was like on the
corner side and we were just going
around in blocks like that and then they
were outside of the car just making out
I think they were drunk cuz everyone was
just wasted so you're alive Brandon yeah
and then Brendan bailed like we just
went straight back to the house and
she's like [ __ ] told on them and then
some [ __ ] happened and I had to go home
because I was like damn that's some
[ __ ] ruined birthday party right I
was like these people are irresponsible
that's crazy that's the first time I
witnessed some [ __ ] like that I was like
I'd like to uh you didn't have trashy
friends I hate getting included in group
chats with a bunch of people I don't
know yes so one time I like to say a
bunch of reckless [ __ ] like what [ __ ] we
like like ten other people and let's say
it's like a girl one time was a girl I
hadn't seen like since high school she
put me in a group chat with whole bunch
of [ __ ] people I didn't know and it
was like parties on Saturday but I was
like I don't know you don't put me in
this so I started applying she's like
but show or he's gonna be late I'll
bring the con and it was like with
people like she was like her boss and
[ __ ] was in there and they're like who
is this please stop texting him like yo
I don't know but I'll see you at the
orgy for so it's gonna be crazy
how did you in the group check the
homegirl that invited us but it was
fighting everybody to the party so I was
like just annoyed with her
yes so I'll just say all types of stupid
say and they're getting so mad I wasn't
have the balls to say that why do it do
it no I just blocked everyone cuz I'm
like [ __ ] why would you include meet
some dump [ __ ] I mean know who you are
know you gotta have fun with them yeah
like when went on Instagram they have
like a [ __ ] 15 people group chat song
like a text yeah oh you know what [ __ ]
it up is when people don't have iPhones
the green Julie I hate that and then you
get individual text out of nowhere no
and it's like babe keep it in the group
chat and you can name the group chat and
[ __ ] that's cool like I feel like Apple
do that on purpose to make the green so
unappealing to look at because
immediately when you see the green
bubbles you're like oh I don't want to
talk to this person see dude at man life
choices blue like the ocean nice and
refreshing yeah green it's like super
watt it's not even a good shade of green
like it's a [ __ ] like neon gross
green toxic man that was smart
yeah even when I meet people are you
networking in whatever and I get their
number on my cool light accent it's a
green theme I'm like oh how do you wanna
world with you anymore
[Laughter]
I go out of my way to like like I have
when I was setting up the group chat for
the bachelor party I texted all the
iPhone homies in one group chat and then
the one homie that had a [ __ ] like
can we guess who it was who it was PT
take him separately hey man is this good
for you everyone else is at cuz I want
to keep it boy yeah I see built his own
laptops and [ __ ] he built his own
computers he does goes underneath the
[ __ ] people I could light up and glow
yeah he seems like one of those fans and
[ __ ] and wires out there we can read you
like they swear they're Sam swings are
better
you ain't special
[Music]